corbin burns who was as good as anybody
in major league baseball this last time
outro yeah no kid he pitched into the
ninth inning against cincinnati that was
in at the reds ballpark eight in the
third five hits no runs one walk 12
punch outs outstanding work for corbin
here he comes swagging a mess he struck
him out
down and away at 96
and the pitch swinging a bouncer hit to
first
easy play
rowdy teles
and he struck him out with breaking ball
blocked by manny pina bray who's going
to give himself up carlos rodon on for
his 17th start looking for his ninth win
as cra at touch over two 140 strikeouts
and 96 and two-thirds with only 26 walks
i mean he's absolutely been brilliant
this year colton wong is all set to
stand in and lead things off for the
crew
and the opening pitch colton wong to
right in deep get up
get up get out of here and go
for colt and wong
he took the first one he saw and hid it
out of here how about that one colton
wong is eighth of the year sitting dead
red got it and knocked it out of here
2-2 slider lifted on the right-hand side
gavin sheets that's out number one
broken bat flare and garcia in place off
the shift for the second out one two
coming
it's a fastball and it's lifted to
center for brian goodwin in the sunlight
basking in out number three
and the pitch swinging and a drive into
left playable yellows
[Applause]
ground ball to short
adonis an easy play for the second out
it's hitting the right garcia
takes care of it another three out of
three down inning for corbin burns all
right it is tyrone taylor whose first
grand slam in the major leagues was one
of the highlights last night
to deep left center did he get enough
goodwin back
back-to-back knights for tyrone taylor
two-nothing brewers
a mistake by rodon and the brewers
making pay two to nothing
the ninth home run allowed by rodon and
a big fly for
tyrone taylor ball is jumping off the
brewers bats tonight given up two runs
already burns gonna try and move the
runners along pops the butt up
it's gonna fall
and the only out is gonna be at first
base boy the brewers catch a break right
there
[Applause]
abreu holds the line at first and that
will do it
got him
nasty cutter down and in
strikeout number three for burns
collins gone working 96
may have got a call there but it's
strikeout number four
one two coming back
put it in play
to adamus
there's a good slider buried in the dirt
and there is the first strikeout for
carlos
02
wave and a miss
strikeout number two for carlos
second base laori garcia
took it away from avi garcia we're only
missing willie garcia
the third diving snap the rings gets up
got him and
these guys are picking it right now they
had a really good month in july
defensively
[Music]
sheets to right
didn't get it all
garcia for out number two
0-2
towards right garcia can't get there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
guys get hot they get cold
and lays down
late to get to the back and it's down
the right field line taylor held it
third as urea sprints to second brewers
playing a little small ball brewers with
second and third and nobody out for
rowdy television
bouncer right side of braves coming home
the throw is high safe at home is taylor
collins not able to make the play in
time and the brewer is on the board
again
and the brewers now lead at three to
nothing gives wong an opportunity base
is still loaded with one-on-one away
gather at the belt again and bring home
the 2-2 with the bases loaded
swing and a miss he got him
so nowhere to put adamus
brewers really making the white sox
all-star starting pitcher work here
tonight
ball four another run in
second walk of the inning
slowly hit to third base orios has no
play and the socks are in business for
the first time this evening burns to
goodwin
[Applause]
ryan goodwin a flare to center field and
this is down that was a trap and that's
a base hit for goodwin the bases are
loaded for the sox so leori garcia will
bat
a little dribbler on the ground out near
the plate the throw by burns is off the
mark to the catcher a run scores
it's four to one great council is going
to come out
and they
are they contending that they must
runner moncotta missed home plate all
right um pires take the headsets off and
he's gonna be out at home they're going
back to new york they're getting on the
headset and they're gonna check on the
22nd rule to make sure that they got
this right
and i guess
the outcall apparently it's going to
stand
it's 4-1
i think i've seen that before
[Applause]
got him
curveball right there burger got on
strikes corbin burns we mentioned the
five strikeouts the brewers are the
first national league team
to strike out a thousand batters in
fewer than a hundred games played and
the pitch
swinging pop-up
right field not deep
[Applause]
gets out of it with no further problem
struck him out
[Applause]
popped him up shallow center out is long
with a play
and the battery is rowdy teles
to lez
deep right center forget about it
off the scoreboard for rowdy his first
as a member of the brewers that's a big
fly for the big man
coming up now home run in the sixth
shot to center back way back it is
a second home run in this ball game stay
hot big man
this one towards right garcia's got a
beat on it makes the catch ball game
over
brewers have won the series and they can
get greedy with a sweep in prime time
tomorrow night